le fmi serait ti de la dernière chance
de la tunisie pour éviter la banqueroute
le pays qui a entamé de nouvelles
discussions avec l'institution
internationale les négociations avec
l'arabie saoudite et des émirats arabes
unis est ton point mort mais ces
pourparlers pourraient aussi se solder
par un échec en l'absence d'un projet de
réforme le point avec notre
correspondant à tunis mais ce schéma
c'est une course contre la montre pour
le nouveau gouvernement de neige la
bouden en pleines discussions techniques
avec le fonds monétaire international
dernier recours avant l'effondrement
économique du pays objectif de tunis
l'octroi d'un crédit de 4 milliards de
dollars pour éviter de devoir activer la
planche à billets autrement dit la
création de monnaie pour financer son
propre fonctionnement au risque d'une
brutale poussée de l'inflation en avril
dernier le fmi avait déjà mis fin aux
échanges avec tunis en l'absence d'un
gouvernement capable de réaliser les
projets sur lesquels deux pays s'était
engagé après la nomination de la jda
bouden la tunisie tente donc de relancer
la communication avec le fmi pas la
surprise de l'institution financière
sans programme de réponse ni de garantie
claire poil d'inside haines expert en
finances la lenteur du gouvernement à
prendre des décisions vitales pour
l'avenir du pays ne fera qu éloignés
davantage la reprise des négociations
avec le fmi écouter ce que je constate
c'est qu'on reprend où on essaye de
reprendre les discussions avec juste une
demande une lettre de la madame lâchait
ne le chef du gouvernement pour dire
prêter nos 4 milliards de là ok mais bon
qu'est ce que vous allez en faire on n'a
pas de réponse on n'a pas de réponse à
deux questions essentielles comment nous
allons financer les dépenses de l'état
pour 2022 et deuxièmement quelles sont
les réformes que nous quand on
entreprend dans le cadre de cette loi de
finances ou au delà de cette pertinence
pour essayer justement de sortir lacunes
de cette situation économique et
financière grave dangereuses sans
précédent dans l'histoire de la tunisie
le temps est déjà passée largement en
aurait dû faire ça en juillet août nous
l'avons pas fait il faut peut-être le
faire maintenant ça risque d'être un peu
bâclé à cause justement de du temps mais
plus à train lui les discussions avec
les familles selon l'ong donc pour le
d'arriver en février mars on est
peut-être d'arriver plus tard parce que
si on s'était présenté au fmi cette fois
ci au moins avec les trois documents
c'est-à-dire loi de finances
complémentaire 2021 loi de finances 2012
pendant un délai folle et on peut
engager à ce moment là une discussion
qui pourrait arriver rapidement à des
négociations
parmi ces réformes la gestion des
dépenses publiques dans un pays tu ne
crée plus de croissance la
régularisation du commerce extérieur
notamment avec la chine et avec elle la
turquie ou encore la réduction de la
masse salariale de la fonction publique
qui représente pas moins de 750 mille
fonctionnaires pour une population d'un
peu moins de 12 millions d'habitants
dans l'incapacité à d'amorcé de telles
réformes la tunisie tente tant bien que
mal de gagner du temps pour éviter un
scénario catastrophe qui l'a plongerait
davantage dans une crise financière
devenue totalement hors de contrôle
absence de loi de finances inflation qui
grimpe à 6,3 pour cent ou encore chômage
à 18% la jeune démocratie semble
s'éloigner jour après jour de l'espoir
qui avait insufflé le coup de force du
président kaïs sayed le 25 juillet
dernier